je suis désolé je suis désolé mais je
suis désolé j'avais mis ma flèche
pourtant vous ne m'avez pas vu mais vous
pouvez désolé à part chômage biens neufs
et réparés au plus j'ai pas le temps de
faire un constat il ya mon père qui veut
faire une attaque françois mary hôpital
géré avec beaucoup ces deux mois il perd
les papiers je ne pouvais être papa ou
enfin constat y on y va et non la
sauvage est aussi celle qui dit papa tu
as toujours tout seul travail et jaune
la vente ton père trouve rien drogue
était accro à sa fin toi ma mort sur la
conscience la peine de faire un constat
qu donné il faut il faut se couvrir
votre père les vigiles ont constamment
telnet regarder je vous donne ça vous
allait réparer votre voiture
non merci
je vous remercie je m'en sors je tiens à
vous remercier car ce débat